[Musique]
tu nous laisses entrée s'il ya une chose
qui ne les intéresse pas c'est ce que
leur parent enfant
[Musique]
un atout mais qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce
qu'il faut regarder c'est ma mère là bas
ces personnes pour promettre à ce que
nous faisons là on est plutôt dans
l'assassinât rituel nous on serait tous
les psychopathes selon toi il va falloir
faire un autre sacrifice runaways
la nouvelle série marvel à partir du
mardi 4 décembre à 21h en exclusivité
sur syfy
une bande d'adolescents confrontés aux
secrets de leurs parents sont des ados
et à une chose qui ne les intéresse pas
c'est ce que leur parent enfant la lutte
du bien contre le mal et les gags de
super pouvoirs et un dinosaure découvrir
au noise la nouvelle série marvel en
exclusivité chaque mardi à 21h sur syfy
runaways est l'adaptation d'un comic
book édité par marvel dans laquelle des
adolescents découvrent que leurs parents
ne sont pas forcément ce qu'il croit
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qu'ils font
drôle de réunion pour une asso
caritatives
6 à 2 8 mois contre les forces du mal
c'est à dire mieux pas mort je crois que
nos parents ont tué ses deux filles et
comme tout bon à dos la joyeuse bond va
mettre tout en oeuvre pour s'opposer à
leurs aînés écoutez si on veut y voir
clair le meilleur moyen c'est peut-être
de mener une enquête et d'éviter de
paniquer certains d'entre eux pouvaient
même se découvrir des pouvoirs
insoupçonnés et à mesure ils vont en
apprendre plus sur eux-mêmes un gardien
découvrir qu'ils ont des capacités qui
les rendent spéciaux je crois que c'est
très chic et son enfant quelque sorte
c'est l'évolution de ces adolescents
géométrie à travers la manifestation de
leurs superpouvoirs m'arrive un truc
vraiment très bizarre
côté casting runaways rassemble des
visages connus des amateurs de séries
comme james marsters le vampire spike
dans buffy julian mcmahon de nip/tuck
gregg sulkin de pretty little liars est
aussi ce
dinosaures
[Musique]
tu as eu le triomphe du bien sur le mal
on est tous que sa machine
c'est ça la signature marvel super
pouvoirs réaction prenons wise la
nouvelle série marvel c'est chaque mardi
21h et en exclusivité sur syfy